i have something i want to talk to you
about i feel like it's not really fair
to you or myself to continue
house living with you
[Music]
it's the end of an era for tariq el musa
and christina hack as their beloved hgtv
series flip or flop airs its final
episode after 10 seasons
and turns out it was all christina's
decision
party's over the series finale shows the
two flipping a spanish style home but
because christina was in tennessee with
her fiance joshua hall she was unable to
do the final walk through in person
the pair ultimately figures out the
listing price but it got the mom of
three thinking about the future i feel
like it's not really fair to you or
myself to continue
i'll still be with you
have you really thought about this i've
thought about it a lot i thought about
it more on the last trip to tennessee
and
i think it's what's best
i can't be at these houses for you like
i should
okay um it's been an amazing run and
there's been ups and downs but it's
mostly been fun
and although the news seemingly came out
of the blue tarik also agrees
i'm pretty surprised that christina's
decision to leave the flipping business
i do wish her the best of luck
but you know sometimes in life change
can be good for everybody
ahead of the finale tarek reflected on
his flipper flop journey alongside
throwback photos with christina
in his caption he thanks the fans crew
and contractors but most importantly
expresses gratitude to his ex-wife whom
he was married to for nine years
writing quote i think we did a pretty
good job and i'm excited for what the
future holds for both of us and wish her
nothing but the best
well that's a end of a legacy here
it's not like we're not going to see
each other this is true or soccer this
weekend still got those two little
monsters
those two little monsters tarik and
christina's kids taylor and braden
earlier this month when the series end
was announced a source told et the two
communicate for the kids but said that
offset they aren't really friends
another source shared with e.t they have
a stable co-parenting relationship but
working together so closely was
sometimes a lot
like the goal is for the kids to feel
happy and settled and that's what we
want the same thing so that really is
how we live and how he projects it and
that's just his personality and it's
trust me it's the best possible
situation for everybody and the two have
since moved on in their personal lives
of course christina married and anstead
back in 2018 and gave birth to their son
hudson the next year but the two
divorced in 2021
and now the hgtv star is engaged to
joshua hall
it's amazing it is it's incredible as
for tariq he married selling sunset star
heather ray young back in october for me
i felt more and more in love with her
every day and i tell her that because
you know we've been together for two and
a half years which is a short period of
time it's also a long period of time and
we're already married but you know as a
relationship moves forward i still am
learning new things about her and like
and just every day we get closer and i
and i think this whole experience has
really brought us together
[Music]